hi I'm Gail Miller be sure the voice of
the Westminster Kennel Club I grew up in
the sport of dogs as a breeder owner
handler and I'm also an AKC licensed
judge and this is every single breed of
dog sporting there are 31 breeds in the
Sporting Group comprised of dogs they
were bred to work with man the first
subgroup is the German Shorthaired
Pointer and the German Wirehaired
Pointer main difference would be having
that wiry coat so that the dog's skin
doesn't get ripped if it's in very thick
brush these are tireless hunters that
are known for being able to work all day
long give me wonderful pets but they
need lots of exercise here we have the
retrievers there's the Chesapeake Bay
Retriever the curly coated retriever the
flat coat retriever the golden retriever
the Labrador Retriever and of course the
Nova Scotia Duck Tolling Retriever the
Chesapeake Bay Retriever is known to
have an oily feel to its coat and that's
to help make it water repellent in those
cold waters the curly coda Retriever is
what's called a silhouette breed they
have a very unique outline the
flat-coated retriever all in black is
always wagging its tail the golden
retriever of course has been a long
family favorite in the United States one
of the top American Kennel Club
registered breeds every year the
Labrador Retriever is used in many
different capacities aside from being a
hunting dog they can be drug sniffing
dogs they're lovable easygoing
temperament makes them versatile and
able to do many jobs the Nova Scotia
Duck Tolling Retriever is a little
smaller than the other retrievers and he
has a very unique
style here we have the English Setter
the Gordon setter Irish setter and the
Irish Red and White setter the Gordon
Center is a little heavier bone that's
important note because they actually
were sitting in Scotland where it was a
rougher terrain than where the other
centers were the English Center is one
of the earliest breeds shown in
Westminster the Irish Red and White
Center is actually a very old breed but
was only eligible to show at Westminster
in 2010 this subgroup is the cocker
spaniels beginning with the English
cocker spaniel and then the ascom cocker
which stands for any solid color other
than black and then the black cocker
spaniel and the party color cocker
spaniel now the English cocker spaniel
is the original and the other three are
the American version the English cocker
spaniel is true to my heart I actually
have one at home I have an orange and
white and I love this breed they're
known as being Mary that's one of the
main characteristics is their tail never
stops wagging then you have the American
caucus as we call them now these have a
different head shape they have a shorter
smaller head they have a shorter muzzle
they're smaller at the withers then the
English cocker spaniel and in the show
ring you'll see them with a much more
perfuse coat so the difference between
the asked Cobb cocker the black cocker
and the party color cocker is really
just the coat color any solid color
other than black means it's either all
buff or it's all of one of the accepted
colors without any white then you have
the all black clearly and then the party
colour is many colours put on the dog
here we have the English Springer
Spaniel and the welsh springer spaniel
but you'll notice they have very
different features and that part of it
is just the ear length the length of
body the height of body but they're both
fun-loving great sporting dogs that are
fun to go work with and can work all day
in the 1970s there was an English
Springer Spaniel who won Best in Show
Westminster two times the Welsh Springer
is a sweet outgoing breed that has that
beautiful red and white coat
that is very protective when they're
hunting here we have the Clumber spaniel
in the Sussex spaniel and the only
reason they're put together is because
they're both heavier bone lower to the
ground they were a slow-moving hunting
dog they weren't built for speed they're
built for endurance they're built for
long distance but not fast
the Clumber spaniel has won best of show
Westminster in 2009 a Sussex spaniel won
best of show at Westminster and holds
the record for being the oldest dog to
ever win vessel show he was 10 years old
here we have the Weimaraner
the Vizsla and the wire hair fish love
these are German and Hungarian breeds
that have been developed over centuries
they are very sleek in their appearance
they're very athletic they need lots of
room and lots of exercise the Vizsla is
a rust color breed they're known for
being very close to their family and not
wanting to be separated from their
family very trainable and very
fun-loving the wire haired Vizsla as the
name says has a little different coat
they're a little more rough looking
little rugged looking that coat is
really just to protect them when they're
hunting and of course the wine runner is
known as the Gray Ghost they're very
athletic strong they needs a lot of
exercise and care the Boykin Spaniel is
one of the few breeds that has webbed
feet so that it can swim better and work
in wet terrain the spaniels that became
very popular in the UK originally came
from Spain and the field spaniel is one
of those they're a little larger than
the English cocker and they're
definitely larger than American cocker
spaniel but they're a very old breed the
Brittany from France from the region of
Brittany
is still used today in hunting scenarios
and competitions hunters love this breed
because of their energy and the fact
that they're so versatile and they're
hunting styles they're very alert and
they like to go go go
the Irish Water Spaniel is a large
spaniel that actually has a rat tail
single coat similar to a poodles coat
beautiful brown coloring and they make
an
Sep tional hunter the lagotto romagnolo
recently joined the westminster ring in
2016 this breed is known as the truffle
hunter and they're a great family pet
the Netherlands Quaker honja is a
beautiful red and white medium-sized dog
that is a true hunter even though they
look like just a cute fun dog they
really are an independent thinker and
they love to hunt it's important to
people know just because they look to
you doesn't mean that they aren't
serious about their jobs the pointer
which is the emblem of the Westminster
Kennel Club is one of the original
breeds entered at the Westminster Show
in 1877 in 1877 when the Westminster
Kennel Club was formed they imported
pointers from England to help strengthen
the breeding stock of Westminster cow
there was a dog brought over named
sensation who then went on to become the
emblem of the Westminster Kennel Club
and that dog is still used in all of our
logos and catalogues and everything we
use today the pointer is a very strong
part of our history
thus Pannonia Italiano is a very
laid-back easygoing dog they're supposed
to be ungroomed unpolished in the ring
they're naturally shown and so sometimes
that can mean a wet beard sometimes that
can mean that their hair just looks like
they woke up and just got out of bed but
that's what we love about the spinelli
aside from their wonderful temperaments
the wire-haired point in Griffon is
known for that tousle look of his
furnishings it's a very serious hunter
but if you want that scruffy looking
face you can get that - Terrier there
are 31 breeds in the terrier group made
up of primarily ratters that came from
England Terra means ground and these
dogs often went underground and would go
under after badger vermin they have to
be very bold and feisty and that's what
you'll find the terrier group here we
have the bare Dale Terrier the carry
blue and the Irish Terrier now
oftentimes these dogs serve multi
purposes meaning that they were used for
ratting of course of being vermin
control but also the larger dogs like
the Airedale were used for all round
farm purposes
there were Airedales that were used in
world war ii as messenger dogs they're
very smart and trainable dog Kerry blue
Terrier has a single coat it's good for
people who might have allergies Irish
Terrier is very plucky they're tall they
have the great deer carrot and some
people thought that and lady in
the trap was may be related to an Irish
Terrier the next subgroup is the
American Staffordshire Terrier and the
Staffordshire Bull Terrier they're very
athletic they're very strong aside from
their athleticism is that they're very
focused here we have the colored bull
terrier the white bull terrier and the
miniature bull terrier now really the
only difference is the markings of the
white and the color bull terrier the
miniature bull terrier clearly is a
smaller version but all of them are
comical they're known for their zest for
life and the white bull terrier of
course became famous when Patton had one
here we have the Smooth Fox Terrier and
the Wire Fox Terrier now they are a
little different in their head shape and
in their bodies obviously the coats
different but the Wire Fox Terrier has
one bestest show Westminster 15 x the
next subgroup is the Norfolk and Norwich
Terrier
now these breed used to be a single
breed and then broke off because the
difference is in the ears one way to
remember Noah folk versus Norwich is the
W the dog with the ears up looks like a
W and that's a witch so that's the
Norwich here we have the Russell Terrier
and the parson Russell terrier and the
main difference in these two dogs is the
parson is a little taller on leg a
little less bone whereas the Russell
Terrier is a little lower to the ground
and a little more bone tool here we have
the Lakeland Terrier and the Welsh
Terrier and although these dogs have a
very similar outline when they're in the
ring being judged against each other is
the judge is looking at the differences
in the head they have a different head
shape and that's characteristic of the
breed here we have the Scottish Terrier
the west highland white terrier and the
see Liam terrier
the Scottie and Westie are often
depicted together in advertising and
different things like that that stark
difference between the black and white
but they're very different dogs all of
them had that Terrier feistiness about
them the Scottie of course has a much
longer head their classic black with the
ears that are upright the Westie has
more fringe around the face and is a
fun-loving white Terrier and then the
see liam is a little thicker they're a
little harder in their body their ears
are flopped down but all three of them
were originally bred to do the same
thing which is vermin control the
American hairless Terrier was recognized
by the AKC in 2016 and debuted at
Westminster in 2017 the Australian
Terrier is a little longer and back
they had that coarse coat and upright
ears the Bedlington Terrier this is the
breed that looks like it's a baby lamb
but it really isn't this dog is a
serious terrier and a serious hunter the
border terrier is known to have the head
similar to an otter they're a wonderful
city dog they're clean they like other
people and other dogs they make a great
family pet the Karen Terrier is a fun
little dog that comes in lots of
different colors the Chesky Terrier
began showing at Westminster in 2012 the
danity Dentmon Terrier is a very long
dog that has unique features like its
very puffy coated head and round eyes
the glint of a ball has a very unique
shape they're supposed to have a rise in
the loin large head with large nose and
a very harsh coat the standard
Manchester Terrier in its black and tan
coat is very alert and ready to go the
miniature schnauzer has long been a
family favorite they're very trainable
they're very popular in lots of dog
sports Rhett Terriers are very portable
and easy to train and they love to be
with their people the Skye Terrier
coming from the Isle of Skye is known
for its very long length of body its
long coat and it has upright ears but it
also comes in drop ears soft-coated
Wheaten is you know
for its beautiful soft coat toy there
are 21 breeds in the toy group the toy
group is comprised of many different
shapes and coat types but really they
were all bred to be companions the first
subgroup is the Affenpinscher and the
Brussels griffons both of them have kind
of that round face with a moustache and
they both have lots of zest for life
the second subgroup is Chihuahuas
there's the smooth-coated and the
long-haired and of course everybody
knows that they think they're a big dog
when they're really not
here we have the english toy spaniels in
the Cavalier King Charles Spaniel these
were all lap dogs of the royalty English
toy spaniels come in the Blenheim and
King Charles which is the red and white
and then there's also the King Charles
and Ruby where they're black and tan or
all red the difference between the
Cavalier King Charles and the English
toys the primarily is in the head and
body length the head shape of the
Cavalier King Charles is a longer muzzle
and different shaped head here we have
the silkie terrior the Yorkshire Terrier
and the Maltese now people sometimes get
the silky Terrier and the Yorkshire
Terrier mixed up because they are
similar in colouring in that they have
to tan with the bluish gray and they
have a long coat but the Yorkshire
terrier is a much smaller head its ears
are a different positioning it's a much
shorter back than the silky terrier so
there are differences then there's also
the Maltese which is a small heavily
coated dog as well but of course that
one's all white here we have the Chinese
Crested and the Pekinese both breeds are
from China but the Chinese Crested was
used as a ratter on ships sometimes was
passed from sailor to sailor because of
how good they were at Bourbon control
whereas the Pekinese stayed in the
palace
they were the companion of royalty the
toy poodle is the smallest of the three
poodle sizes they are known as being
very intelligent and they're a great
family pet the toy fox terrier can be
very good at agility they're quick and
they're good listeners the Havanese is
the only breed native to Cuba the
Italian Greyhound is a very old breed
but were in fact entered at the first
Westminster Kennel Club
dog show in 1877 the Japanese chin has a
very unique head and face it's light to
pick up they're easy to grow they were
highly regarded in Japan and have been
showing at Westminster for 144 years the
toy manchester terrier is a smaller
version of the standard manchester
terrier and has a lot of the same
temperament and features of the breed
the miniature pinscher is a lot of dog
in a small package they are fearless and
they have a very unique gait it's like
the Papillon is called such because of
their ears Papillon and French means
butterfly so they're the butterfly dog
the Pomeranian has a very thick coat and
comes in many colors the Pug is recorded
as being in existence since 400 BC there
were pugs showing it the first
Westminster Kennel Club dog show in 1877
the Shih Tzu comes in many different
colors they have a beautiful coat but if
you want to keep the coat short at home
you can do that and have a great little
family member working there are 30 dogs
in the working group comprised of breeds
that were bred to either protect to
guard or to rescue these are strong
breeds that have a lot of focus and work
ethic the first subgroup is the Alaskan
Malamute the Sam Yeng and a Siberian
Husky these three breathe have heavy
coats they're supposed to work in very
cold temperatures and they can pull very
heavy loads the Alaskan Malamute is a
very large dog and needs to be
socialized at a young age
sandhya it looks like it's smiling
because of the black pigment around the
lips on that white coat the Siberian
Husky is won Best in Show at Westminster
one time here we have the Anatolian
Shepherd the Komondor and the kuvasz
these three breeds they are very
protective of the flock and that was
their job to work independently of the
humans that they know their job and
they'll take care of business
the anatolian breed is more than 6,000
years old the Komondor has a corded coat
the kuvasz is fearless yet sweet here we
have the bland burger and the Tibetan
Mastiffs both of our big coated breeds
don't be fooled by the Leonberger size
they're playful they're friendly and
make great pets the Tibetan Mastiff is
an independent thinker and when it comes
to training you have to make sure that
you're working on their level here we
have the dog de bordo the boxer and the
Connie Corso they have different head
shapes and they have different
temperaments but they're all very strong
breeds they're smooth coated sometimes
they drool a little bit they have become
very well known in our country Dogue de
Bordeaux has been in movies the boxer
has been a longtime family friend and
the Connie Corso is just becoming more
popular as a strong dog that is both
protector and family member here we have
the Doberman Pinscher and the Rottweiler
two German breeds that are very well
known for being good working dogs they
are very versatile and can do many
different tasks the Doberman Pinscher
aside from its stare is a beautiful dog
very athletic
the popular Rottweiler is a confident
Guardian here we have the giant
schnauzer and the standard schnauzer
both of these are German breeds they're
very trainable they've been used before
as military dogs today they make
wonderful pets they have a coarse coat
which makes it easy for them to stay
clean they can be trimmed so that you
don't have to worry about the
furnishings when gripping the dog the
giant schnauzer comes in two colors all
black or salt-and-pepper
the next subgroup are dogs that you
would find in the mountains originally
there's the Bernese Mountain Dog the
greater Swiss Mountain Dog the Great
Pyrenees and the Saint Bernard
these dogs are not necessarily related
but they all could have been found in
the mountains
the Bernese Mountain Dog has that
traditional tricolour of the swiss
breeds the greater Swiss Mountain Dog
has a smooth coat the Great Pyrenees is
Murli all white the st. Bernard is known
for its large bone it's big head and big
heart here we have the bull mastiff
mastiff the Neapolitan Mastiff and the
barbel these were all estate guardians a
male bull mastiff can average 120 pounds
mastiff is one of the originals of the
Mastiff Bream's the Neapolitan Mastiff
was featured in the Harry Potter series
the boerboel debuted at Westminster in
here we have the Newfoundland and de
Portuguese water dog both dogs are used
in the water the Newfoundland was a
water rescue dog with jump off boats and
go and help people that have been thrown
into the water and bring down to safety
and the Portuguese water dog would help
fishermen pull Nets back into the boats
the Akita needs early socialization and
training the Black Russian terrier is a
very large dog don't let the word
terrier fool you the Chinook is one of
the few original American breeds the
German pincer is more closely associated
with the schnauzer than other pincers
the Great Dane comes in several
different colors one of my favorites is
Harlequin where it's black and white
[Music]
that was all 205 breeds that show at the
Westminster Kennel Club dog show
and as far as we're concerned they're
all Best in Show